in America socialism is hot again
democratic socialism is your kids public
school it's our interstate highway
systems the researchers and scientists
paid with our taxes we can do better
when we do them together really I know
better because I'm from Guatemala I've
seen the impact of socialism my father
escaped Cuba my grandfather suffered
under communists in Hungary before
escaping as a child I was thought
socialism was wrong
I grew up mocking it but democratic
socialism sounded okay it made sense to
me that government should take care of
the economy it's complete anarchy but
then I watched socialism fail in Latin
America nada I learned that every time a
country started down the socialist path
it failed when Castro came to power
people were excited they cheered he was
going to help the poor and make everyone
equal but there is salt sailing for
freedom aboard an old green Chevy truck
hundreds of thousands fled Cuba here in
Little Havana in Miami
humans who escaped are eager to remind
people how bad life in Cuba had become
this man's father was a doctor my father
had to sell illegal meat out of his
ambulance in Cuba because the government
wouldn't pay him enough I mean Cuban
doctors and like less than 1% than
American doctors you don't see any
future everything is stagnated
healthcare education nowadays daring
ruins I told a Venezuelan my penicillin
friends we want you guys Bennis wallah
did not listen they followed Google
Chavez down the socialist path la grande
la grande rakissa kkd 3 will pour avoir
de manera kita Teva Chavez promises
impressed American celebrities -
fascinating guy this is you and Hugo
shop
help me write my speech kill capitalism
already know the language please have a
said I'll take from the rich and give to
the poor when there was no money left
the government just printed more that
cost inflation a million percent
inflation now a chicken costs this much
venezuela has of today the highest
inflation in the world when business
owners raise prices to keep up with
inflation government often took away
their businesses that's what's happening
to this man Travis sees lots of private
property yesterday vco Travis sees
thousands and thousands of businesses
just took them away from their owners
yet most - Whelan's like that people was
clapping so hard they were like oh
finally there's somebody here making
social justice but government grabbing
private businesses created shortages of
almost everything why did you leave your
country just like the apocalypse it's no
food no medicine how do you feel when
you see other countries with the same
mistakes that Cuba has made for the past
decades terrible michel ivara
escaped Cuba and says Venezuela should
have learned from Cuba's failure people
in other countries in Latin America they
will blame anything else besides
socialist blaming socialism for
Venezuela's riches-to-rags story is
grossly misleading and there are plenty
of socialist countries that look nothing
like Venezuela when I talk about
democratic socialism I'm not looking at
Venezuela I'm not looking at Cuba I'm
looking at countries like Denmark and
Sweden why not try my Swedish to do
Scandinavia is now called a socialist
success even people jailed in Venezuela
like Francisco Marquez say that I mean
you have no way you have Finland you
have these type of countries that are
democratic that have democratic
institutions and many of them have
socialist policies in Scandinavia
private business is largely left alone
governments don't even set a minimum
wage freedom rankings core Scandinavian
countries high on property rights and
business freedom all Danes enjoy welfare
benefits yes there's a big welfare state
but it's funded by thriving free
enterprise there we go
Denmark but so many American politicians
say Denmark is a socialist paradise that
Denmark's Prime Minister felt compelled
to reply Denmark is far from socialist
plant economy Denmark is a market
economy
so if Scandinavia is not socialist where
has socialism ever worked nowhere why
would you say to the Americans that like
the idea of socialism and supported here
I would say that they should wake up and
you don't need the government to dictate
how your how to live your life how much
money you should make how your family
should be treated or how much you should
pay if anything I think taxes are still
a bit high here but it's the best we
have in the entire world think about
that the next time you hear Michael
Moore and celebrities praising socialism
socialism wrecks economies wrecks lives
and in addition it kills in my next
video I'll show you why under socialism
violence is inevitable
[Music]